there was a whacked out event at Trump's
Doral Resort in Florida where Dr Peter
McCullough one of the big we I guess I
would call him like an anti-vac
pseudoscience dignitary Who Rose in the
age of covid Dr Peter McCullough see if
you can follow this okay he suggested at
this completely Bonkers event
the covet vaccines
cause autism
autism turns people trans
therefore using our what is that the
commutative property from algebra
pre-algebra therefore vaccinations cause
trans this is really weaponized stuff it
must be something happening to the
children something in the in the air in
the water or the food one theory is that
it's hyper vaccination from an
accelerating childhood vaccine schedule
huh so he's saying it's it's vaccines in
general not even just the covet vaccine
that's a theory
it's not really a theory we spoke about
this yesterday on the voicemail it's not
actually a theory in the scientific
sense it's the idle speculation
of someone who has no basis in fact for
making the claim
oh yeah Manhattan
batism and how can we stop it because
once it's present I can tell you as a
doctor it's very difficult to treat and
as as a parent any of you with autistic
children know as a parent it can take
everything you have as a person
sometimes for the rest of your life as a
couple to deal with a severely autistic
uh affected child
all of you know that
autism now
is critically linked as these children
are coming forward in large numbers
to transgenderism whoa the two are
linked
imagine cheering for them
so do an inventory of what you have do
an inventory of your family any of your
friends gather together and understand
this mental contagion is infectious and
it's spreading and we've seen the
chapters now
coveted the illness
coveted vaccination a wave of autism
that's just burning us and now
transgenderism these all right so again
the argument he's making is vaccines
cause autism autism causes Trends now a
little background on Dr Peter McCullough
he regularly has spread uh baseless and
ultimately debunked medical
misinformation he's a cardiologist he
said we should be using
hydroxychloroquine for treating covid
that was determined he said that at a
time when there was no actual good
science saying that that was effective
we ultimately found found out
hydroxychloroquine is not effective for
covet he did the same thing with
Ivermectin at a time when we didn't have
a reason to believe Ivermectin was
affected ultimately a double-blind
randomized controlled trials determined
Ivermectin is not effective and on and
on and on now let's talk about a couple
different things here first of all the
wave of autism
there is a question and we're going to
actually do an interview on the show
about this coming up is there really
more and more autism or are we now
understanding how to better diagnose it
and there were lots of people who 20
years ago would never have been
diagnosed but they were autistic I've
spoken to friends of mine about
classmates we had in third fourth grade
and we now realize and they have since
been diagnosed as autistic in their 20s
and 30s they were always autistic
it just wasn't understood as well at the
time and so there's a question as to
whether there is a wave of autism or the
diagnostic criteria or better understood
regardless there's no evidence that
vaccines cause autism this all goes back
to 1998
Dr Andrew Wakefield put a study out in
the Lancet prestigious medical journal
the study has since been retracted and
Wakefield has lost his license it
claimed on the basis of 12 children that
there was a link between the MMR vaccine
and autism the study was retracted
Wakefield was found guilty of fraud
ethical violations Financial conflicts
of interest the data was bias selective
and falsified and he lost his medical
license
even if vaccines caused autism which
they don't there's no logical or
biological reason why autism would turn
people trans some autistic people may
identify as trans most don't some trans
people may be autistic most are not
there's no evidence that vaccines cause
autism and that autism influences gender
identity but this is a hero to the Maga
right this is the Maga Republican right
at an event held at Trump's Doral Resort